I am back.
Where were we?
We were saying that we know that
velocity, or kind of a
change in velocity, is
acceleration times time.
I just wrote that a little bit
more formally, really kind of
incorporating the change
in velocity.
Right?
The final velocity is equal to
the initial velocity plus
acceleration times time.
I actually could have written
it like this: I could have
written vf minus vi is equal
to acceleration times time,
and this is the change
in velocity.
Actually, that's the way
I should be doing it.
As you can tell, I kind of do
some of this stuff on the fly,
but I do that for a reason--
it's because I want you to get
the same intuition that I
hopefully have, instead of
just kind of doing it in a very
formal way in a book, and
sometimes the book doesn't
necessarily make the
connections in the
most natural way.
This is going straight from my
brain to this video, and
hopefully into your brain.
These are all ways of saying the
same thing, and I actually
should write this as change in
velocity-- that triangle, or
delta, just means change.
The final velocity, my initial
velocity, is equal to
acceleration times time.
The average velocity, you could
just figure-- you take
the final, and you take the
initial, and you average the
two, and it's equal to this.
Then I said, we know what the
final velocity is-- this is
the final velocity, and the
average velocity is this.
We substitute it for the final
velocity, and then we came to
this equation for average
velocity.
Then before I almost ran out of
time, I said I'm going to
take this formula for the
average velocity-- and I
really encourage you to just
play around with these
formulas yourself and derive
it yourself, because it's
going to pay huge rewards later
on when you forget the
formulas on your exam, but you
can work it out anyway.
We have this formula for average
velocity, and let's
substitute it back into this, so
we can say that distance is
equal to the average velocity,
and that's this: vi plus at
over 2 times time.
If we just distributed that t,
we have the initial velocity
times time, plus acceleration
times time squared over 2.
So, distance is equal to the
initial velocity-- let me draw
a line here, so we don't confuse
things-- distance is
equal to the initial velocity
times time plus acceleration
times time squared
divided by 2.
Sometimes the physics teacher
might just teach at squared
2-- that's sometimes what people
memorize, and that's
because in a lot of these
projectile motion problems,
your initial velocity is 0,
especially when you're
dropping a rock.
If your initial velocity is 0,
this term would cancel out.
If you do that last problem that
we just did using this
example, you'll get
the same answer.
I said we're accelerating with
gravity, so a is equal to 10
meters per second squared,
then time is equal to 2
seconds, and then initial
velocity is equal to 0, and
let me make some space here.
The initial velocity is 0-- so
this term just cancels out--
plus acceleration, 10
meters per second
squared times time squared.
You have 10 meters per second
squared times time squared,
time is two seconds,
so it's 4.
Since we've squared the number,
we should also square
the units, so it's 4 seconds
squared, and all of
that is over 2.
Like we learned before-- 10
times 4 divided 2 is 20, and
we have seconds squared the
denominator and we have
seconds squared in the
numerator here.
They cancel out, and we're
just left with meters.
Actually, I'm going to leave it
there for now, and in the
next presentation, I'll
explore some of these
mechanics even further.
I'll see you soon.